[Musique]
est-ce qu'à une période de stabilité en
haïti est ce que ça a été est ce que ça
existe et je la fais plus de cent ans
que l'on avait assisté à l'assassinât
d'un président de la république d'haïti
l'état de droit a été véritablement mise
à mal pour permettre l'assassinât sur un
mode de crapuleux on a vu en fait se
constituer des armées privées qui
aujourd'hui ont totalement perdu le
contrôle de leur trou et lorsque ces
gangsters sont recrutés par des hommes
politiques ça vous donne une situation
pratiquement de guerre civile nous
sommes ici au coeur d'un système
extrêmement un briquet d'intérêt à la
fois intérieure et extérieure de toute
façon
mafieux cela ne peut que contribuer à la
dé construction d'un état moderne et
démocratique
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque jour du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h tron pour décrypter les
grands titres de l'actualité
au sommaire de ce lundi 6 septembre
l'appel à la résistance d'arman massoud
à tous les afghans quelques heures après
la prise supposé par des talibans de la
région du panchir derniers bastions à
tomber le fils de l'illustré commandant
assassiné en 2001 qui avait justement
rendu célèbre cette vallée peut-il être
entendu l'afghanistan au menu de la
visite d' anthony blinken également à
doha aujourd'hui le qatar devenu
incontournable dans les négociations
avec les insurgés décryptage avec nos
invités
il n'y aura pas de chasse aux sorcières
en guinée conakry une promesse faite par
les militaires à l'origine du coup de
force de ce dimanche ses soldats des
forces spéciales ont capturé hier le
président alpha condé a annoncé la
dissolution des institutions un putsch
qui a suscité des scènes de liesse parmi
la population mais qui a été condamné
par la communauté internationale la
france et la russie en tête
et puis à 21h notre nouveau rendez-vous
qu'en pensent les français nous irons ce
soir la rencontre de ces anti passe
sanitaire déterminée à ne pas lâcher
face à un dispositif qu'ils jugent
liberticide
ils sont souvent assimilés à des anti
vaccins mais le sont-ils vraiment déjà
plus d'un mois de mobilisation et un
dossier épineux pour l'exécutif à huit
mois de la présidentielle
alors quelles stratégies pour les partis
politiques dans la course à la
présidentielle le pass annie terre où la
vaccination obligatoire on en débattra
[Musique]
un bastion historique de rébellion le
panchir a fini par tomber aux mains des
talibans qu'ils se félicite d'être enfin
sorti du marasme de la guerre cette
vallée est perdue sur rendu célèbre on
s'en souvient par le commandant massoud
et c'est par la voix de son fils qui a
été lancé un appel à la résistance et au
soulèvement de tout le peuple afghan
françois est risqué beach
les combats ont été violents
après plusieurs jours d'affrontements
avec les membres armés du front national
de résistance
l'état libre annonce ce lundi matin la
prise complète de la vallée du panjshir
avec ses deux victoires notre pays est
désormais complètement sorti du marasme
de la guerre les gens vivront maintenant
dans la liberté et la paix la prospérité
des insurgés ont été tués et le reste a
fui la respectable population du
penthière a été sauvé des preneurs
d'otages
nous lui assurons que personne ne fera
l'objet de discriminations ils sont tous
nos frères et nous travaillerons
ensemble pour un pays et un objectif
enclavé difficile d'accès la vallée du
panjshir était le dernier foyer
d'opposition armée aux talibans une zone
rendu célèbre par le commandant massoud
à la fin des années 1990 avant que ce
dernier ne soit assassiné par al qaïda
deux jours avant les attentats du 11
septembre 2001 elle abrite depuis le
front national de résistance afghane
dirigée par le fils du commandant
massoud ahmad masood est composée de
milices locales ainsi que d'anciens
membres des forces de sécurité afghanes
arrivé dans la vallée lorsque le reste
l'afghanistan est tombé sur son compte
twitter le fnr promet qu'il continuera
le combat
l'affirmation des talibans est fausse
les forces du fnr sont présentes dans
toutes les positions stratégiques de la
vallée pour poursuivre le combat nous
assurons peuple d'afghanistan que la
lutte contre les talibans et leurs
partenaires se poursuivra jusqu'à ce que
la justice et la liberté préval quelques
heures plus tôt le front national de
résistance avait proposé un cessez le
feu après avoir subi de lourdes pertes
au cours des derniers jours dont son
principal porte parole le journalisme
fahim dashty
et après la chute du poker qui donne aux
talibans le contrôle entier du pays
antony blinken vient d'arriver à doha
pour entamer des négociations et créer
un front uni d'allier alors comment les
etats-unis en sont ils arrivés à
soustraire le dossier explosif à un gant
au qatari nous retrouvons notre
correspondant à new york thomas bonnet
bonsoir thomas anthony blinken qui
atterrit donc à doigts pour parler de la
crise en afghanistan à quoi s'attendre
de cette visite
mais c'est en quelque sorte une forme de
visites de remerciement pour anthony
blinken avec ce pays le qatar qui a joué
un rôle majeur on le sait ces derniers
jours lors de l'évacuation en
afghanistan puisque plus de cinquante
mille afghans sont arrivés au qatar lors
de cette opération d'évacuation anthony
blinken qui doit aussi gérer le dossier
justement des l'évacuation des derniers
ressortissants américains toujours en
afghanistan actuellement il faut
rappeler aussi que le qatar c'est un
pays important parce que c'est un pays
où les hommes les américains ont une
base importante plus de onze mille
soldats américains c'est l'une des plus
grandes bases au moyen-orient pour les
états unis et puis on sait que le qatar
a joué un rôle majeur ces dernières
années dans les discussions justement
entre les taliban et washington en
abritant l les pourparlers entre les
deux camps puisque a dès 2018 déjà il y
avait eu des discussions à l'époque déjà
pour parler du retrait à venir des
troupes américaines d'afghanistan
le qatar qui tente aussi de faire passer
les messages des pays occidentaux auprès
des talibans puisqu'il sait on sait
qu'ils ont un dialogue justement avec
les talibans en afghanistan
il presse notamment actuellement les
talibans de former un gouvernement le
plus rapidement possible et le plus elle
inclusif possible autre dossier poussé
par doha c'est celui de l'aéroport de
kaboul doha souhaite que les talibans
puissent rouvrir au plus vite l'aéroport
de kaboul afin de pouvoir et notamment
est affrété de l'aide humanitaire
évidemment les états unis supervise tout
cela en coulisses et c'est d'ailleurs
une des raisons pour lesquelles anthony
blinken se rend au qatar or ce moment il
va rencontrer
moi le premier ministre mais aussi le
chef de la diplomatie qatarienne lors de
son déplacement en déplacement qui se
poursuivra ensuite en allemagne pour
visiter un centre de transit où quelques
trente mille personnes évacuées
d'afghanistan où transitent et justement
ces derniers jours là encore c'est une
façon pour les états unis de remercier
les ailiers qui les ont aidés dans cette
opération d'évacuation particulièrement
chaotique et qui continue de
cristalliser un grand nombre de
critiques contre le gouvernement
américain merci thomas abonnés en direct
de new-york négocier donc pour éviter
que l'afghanistan se transforme en
poudrière en créant un front uni
d'allier après la prise de la vallée du
panchir dernier bastion des résistants
mais par le fils du commandant massoud
ces derniers disposent d'une marge de
manoeuvre leur appel à la résistance at
il des chances d'aboutir c'est l'objet
de notre décryptage ce soir
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison à vos côté régis le
sommier grand reporter qui connaît
évidemment très bien l'afghanistan
puisque régis vous avez passé trois
semaines pour un reportage en juillet
bonsoir donc à tous les deux merci
d'être avec nous cette vallée un dernier
foyer d'opposition aux talibans qui
serait tombée selon ces derniers alors
pas forcément selon le front national de
résistance déjà qui doit-on croire
registre et sonic je pense qu'à l'heure
actuelle il faut croire les talibans
même si il ya des villes va restait des
poches de registre de résistance dans le
temps de sheer qui est une vallée très
très escarpé c'est un cetain comment un
couloir de montagne entre deux montagnes
qui est très difficile d'atteindre pour
rappel quand l'union soviétique avait
envahi l'afghanistan il ya eu quatre
assauts sur le panchir et jamais aucun
n'a abouti et le commandant massoud est
sous le joug soviétique et sous les
taliban a continué à résister donc il
est fort à parier que son fils aussi à
peut-être les moyens de résister dans
des endroits isolés ce sont des
montagnards ce sont des gens qui sont
habitués à la haute montagne le la
vallée du panjshir culmine à 5600 mètres
et donc ils sont capables de voilà
d'avoir eu des points de résistance
néanmoins là les talibans quand même
pénétré dans la vallée ils ont quand
même repris un certain nombre de
districts on peut considérer que ils ont
conquis en gros ils ont atteint leur
objectif
faut le rappeler avec beaucoup d aide de
la part de l'armée pakistanaise mais
dont je vous suis bien c'est très
symbolique ce qui vient de se passer
bien sûr et c'est la bannière fois qu
bien sûr une belle prise puisque c'est
la première fois que les taliban
parviennent à prendre cette vallée val
et symbole de leur résistante par parme
et par dessus tout ahmad shah massoud
qui a été donc tu es le on le rappelle
le 9 septembre 2001 donc il ya 20 ans
quasiment voilà que blanchemaison l'iran
a condamné fermement cet assaut contre
le pen scheer une une critique
d'ailleurs la première de téhéran depuis
la prise de pouvoir des talibans
pourquoi cette première critique à ce
moment là hier le gouvernement iranien
s'était exprimé en disant qu'il fallait
résoudre le problème par le dialogue
en présence d'ailleurs des chefs
traditionnels des différentes tribus et
aux rites et je crois qu'il ya trois
motifs à la latitude de le lire en cas
une frontière très longue avec
l'afghanistan le premier c'est que
l'iran n'a pas envie d'avoir un voisin
dans lequel il y a des troubles qui
pourraient se répandre ailleurs le
second c'est que
l'iran n'a pas envie d'avoir un voisin
failli or l'afghanistan est un pays en
fait puisque 75% des recettes
budgétaires c'était là d'international
et que l'aide internationale
elle est suspendue elle n'arrive plus
par conséquent il ya là un problème très
très important et puis troisièmement en
effet comme ça vient d'être dit l'iran
est très inquiet du rôle que joue le
pakistan le pakistan protecteur
historique des talibans et qui se
manifeste un peu partout d'abord imran
khan s'est réjoui un petit peu
bruyamment le 15 août de la victoire des
talibans et puis aujourd'hui le chef des
services secrets
militaires et interservices du pakistan
est à kaboul alors bien sûr il est là
pour des contacts techniques en réalité
on sait qu'il est là pour organiser un
commandement unifié de la nouvelle armée
argane qui réunira à la fois les
talibans ce qu'ils ont récupéré
l'ancienne armée afghane mais aussi les
les chefs de guerre traditionnels les
seigneurs de la guerre comme on disait
auparavant et qu'il est là aussi sans
doute pour mettre un terme aux querelles
inter talibane et pour aider à la
formation d'un gouvernement d'un
gouvernement taliban
on va en parler évidemment de ce
gouvernement tout d'abord je voudrais
vous faire écouter jeu souvent cet appel
du fils du commandant massoud à la
résistance et côté
où que vous soyez de dans mon dehors de
l'afghanistan je vous appelle à lancer
un soulèvement national pour la dignité
la liberté et la prospérité de notre
pays on a commencé à en parler tout à
l'heure régis le sommier mais à quel
point cet appel peut-il être entendu est
ce que cette résistance est ce qu elle a
un petit peu de chance justement de
résister et de gêner l'expansion énorme
des talibans je pense qu'aujourd'hui
c'est quand même largement trop tôt pour
le dire ce qu'on a pu le montrer ce
qu'on a pu remarquer de toute façon donc
en afghanistan c'est que les talibans ne
doivent pas oublier que l'afghanistan
qu'il récupère aujourd'hui n'est pas
tout à fait le même que celui qu'ils
avaient laissé pour pendant leur chute
il y a vingt ans largement les villes se
sont ouvertes sur le monde
kaboul a été occidentalisée s'ils ont pu
le dire a vécu à l'unisson avec le reste
de la planète et l'idée d'une chape de
plomb
traditionalistes et d'un gouvernement
obscurs comme il est comme il s'était
exercé entre 96 et 2001 est quelque
chose que beaucoup de gens dans les
villes notamment pour eux c'est assez
insupportable de revenir à ça et les
talibans le savent ils sont allés à
l'offensive dans la communication cette
fois ci il n'y a pas eu les exactions il
ya eu des exactions mais il n'y a pas eu
des exactions publiquement admise qui
avait été locale qui avait salué leur
victoire en 96 avec des pendaisons des
lapidations des assassinats dans les
stades tout ça n'a pas lieu cette
fois-ci les talibans savent très bien
que ils jouent gros ils jouent leur
survie il joue aussi un moment critique
vous avez évoqué les seigneurs de la
guerre tout à fait ils sont seuls ceux
là veulent conserver leurs prérogatives
il ya des tensions entre les talibans
entre notamment la branche militaire et
une branche entre guillemets plus
modérée incarné par le mollah baradar
encore que le mollah baradar est un
ancien compagnon de route du mollah omar
de la précédente équipe et que le chef
des talibans aujourd'hui le akoun zada
le mollah akoun zada était responsable
de l'administration de la justice de
l'ancienne équipe talibane donc on peut
pas dire que ce soit fondamentalement
des modérés si vous voulez mais ils sont
prêts à jouer une carte internationale
ils ont envie que de renouer des liens
avec leurs voisins ils sont participer
partiellement parvenu on parlait de
l'iran tout à l'heure l'iran s'est
rapproché des talibans ce qui n'était
pas le cas avant 2001 elle avait même
l'iran avait même fait partie de la
coalition contre les talibans en
novembre 2001 qui avaient peu conduit à
la chute du régime donc aujourd'hui la
plupart des pays autour veut avoir des
relations avec les talibans et les
talibans un défi majeur c'est bien
d'être dans les campagnes avec des
kalachnikovs de faire peur à tout le
monde et ensuite d'arriver et de
conquérir le pays ensuite maintenant le
défi il est économique le défilé
sociétal également et on a vu où parler
de l'opposition effectivement le ahmad
masood incarne une forme de cette
opposition moi je la vois plus tôt
aujourd'hui dans les femmes qui
manifestent dans les villes qu'ils
n'hésitent pas à venir braver les
combattants taliban qui ne qui les
respectent il ya des tensions mais ya
pas eu de 2,2 d'incidents et des femmes
ont pu montrer donner leur voix et
montrer qu'elles sont là et ça c'est des
femmes qui ont bénéficié de l'éducation
aujourd'hui les talibans ont dit que les
universités étaient à nouveau admise
pour les femmes à condition de porter un
une comment le niqab et la bahia
d'accord mais au moins les femmes
peuvent aller à l'université ce qui
n'était pas le cas avant 2001 donc il ya
quand même des choses qui avancent et
cette résistance elle est peut-être un
carnet justement par ces gens là claude
gans maison justement j'allais y venir à
cette manifestation des femmes à à
kaboul qui n'a pas été effectivement
trop contrarié est-ce qu'on est
peut-être dans la communication de la
part des talibans qui cherchent à voile
à être crédible un interlocuteur
crédible ou est ce que comme le dit
régis le sommier ça pourrait être
peut-être là la future résistance de
l'afghanistan même si la grande question
il ya un débat dans quelle mesure les
talibans ont ils changé et elle sont ils
les mêmes outils les changer par rapport
à la dernière fois qu'ils étaient au
pouvoir entre 96 et 2001 alors ils ont
changé dans une certaine mesure de toute
façon le monde a changé autour d'eux et
ils s'en rendent bien compte et ils ont
appris beaucoup de choses il parle
anglais pour beaucoup l'ont en tout cas
leurs responsables ce qui était au qatar
ont pu négocier pendant des mois et des
mois avec les américains le fameux
mollah baradar qui se présente comme la
face
acceptable du mouvement qui pourrait
peut-être devenir premier ministre dans
un gouvernement fait pour séduire
l'extérieur mais en effet il ya des un
testing parce que fondamentalement leur
socle fondamental c'est le socle
religieux et il est le même pour tous
sur le plan religieux je crois pas qu'il
y ait des modérés et les extrémistes ils
sont tous en effet pour une application
stricte de leur interprétation du coran
de leur interprétation de la vie du
prophète de l'arête interprétation de la
jurisprudence etc et c'est une
interprétation qui est extrêmement
respectives et à dire que les femmes
n'ont pas vraiment de place alors en
effet moyennant un certain nombre de
conditions dont certaines sont
totalement ridicules il faut que les
jeunes filles à l'université sorte avant
les garçons on les stocke dans une pièce
ou un amphithéâtre qui n'existent pas
qu'elles attendent que les garçons sont
pas sortis pour ensuite pouvoir sortir
elle même mais en réalité l'épreuve de
vérité va être le gouvernement et le
gouvernement y aura-t-il des femmes je
pense que non y aura-t-il des gens qui
ne soient pas des talibans par exemple
abdallah abdallah qui en rêvent
probablement il aura un strapontin ainsi
la branche
baradar obtient ce qu'elle veut obtenir
hamid karzaï s'est plus douteux mais il
aura peut-être un poste honorifique là
aussi il s'agit de séduire l'occident
est de faire lever les sanctions et et
d'obtenir l'aide internationale ce qui
est ce qui est maintenant en effet vital
pour le pour le pays avant de vous
donner la parole en légiste le sommier
on va écouter le secrétaire d'état
américain qui au qatar on en reparlera
si on a le temps
effectivement qui soit aussi ce
gouvernement inclusif
nous espérons que tout gouvernement mis
en place aura une vraie inclusivité
qu'il y aura dedans des noms talibans
qui soit représentatif des différentes
communautés et des différents intérêts
en afghanistan
et enregistre souvenez ce souhait de
voir des femmes au gouvernement c'est un
souhait l'apurement qui dans ta lou ça
qu'on va perdu d'avancé du mal à
imaginer une fois mon gouvernement
taliban c'est un combat mon avis perdu
d'avancé ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
dans le parlement afghan précédemment il
y avait beaucoup de femmes viennent
avait il y en avait un certain nombre
donné de la voix d'ailleurs certaines
parlementaires étaient très incisif
notamment sur le droit des femmes et
combattait à la fois les talibans et
aussi certains certaines comment
certains seigneurs de guerre à
l'intérieur du gouvernement ou des gens
qui étaient proches du gouvernement donc
le combat des femmes avaient commencé
déjà avant maintenant ce que je vois
dans l'est dans le discours de blink n 7
ce souhait d'inclusivité il s'est tout
simplement le plan que les américains
avaient souhaité avec les talibans à
partir de février de 2020 quand ils ont
fait cet accord de paix avec les
talibans et talibans d'une certaine
façon l'on respecté vis-à-vis des
américains n'ont pas tenu leurs
promesses vis à vis du gouvernement
afghan mais vis-à-vis des américains
partir de février 2020 ya plus un soldat
américain qui est blessé ou tué par un
tir talibans donc là d'une certaine
façon des traînées oui ils sont tenus
mais ce que voient les américains
douglas est l'intérêt d'avoir un
gouvernement inclusif d'essayer de faire
pression là-dessus les talibans on a vu
de l'autre que de l'autre côté habitent
ou là l'autre jour d'hier nous
souhaitons avoir de bonnes relations
avec les états unis donc on est
finalement dans le prolongement de tous
ces accords et que voilà même si le
départ des américains a été extrêmement
chaotique pour les américains c'était
quelque chose qui devait avoir lieu bein
kane et byden l'on dit
que ce soit aujourd'hui ou dans 5 ans ça
n'aurait rien changé à la configuration
du pays donc autant partir la question
aujourd'hui c'est que d'un point de vue
géopolitique l'afghanistan n'intéresse
plus les américains ils veulent juste
partir en laissant le moins
d'instabilité possible dans la région
c'est leur souhait c'est également leur
souhait pour le monde arabe puisqu'il ya
quand même l'amérique est sur une
position de retrait de ces guerres et
deux de ses interventions qui ont duré
des décennies donc donc quelque part les
américains essayer de jouer la pression
sur ce nouveau gouvernement taliban en
espérant potentiellement avoir quelques
personnes qui puissent d'une certaine
façon apporter un gage de modération est
un gage de stabilité pour l'ensemble de
la région voilà qu'à le suspense reste
entier pour l'instant on ne connaît pas
le visage de ce nouveau gouvernement ont
parlé d' anthony blinken un secrétaire
d'état américain qui est attendu au
qatar là d'un instant à l'autre on en
parlait avec thomas bonnet le canard
qatar décidément qui est devenu
incontournable dans ce dossier afghan et
au qatar le secrétaire d'état à la
défense américain y arrive ce soir je
crois
le ministre des affaires étrangères
britannique qui était il ya peu de temps
la france a envoyé d'ailleurs un
représentant un ambassadeur pour sonder
un peu les talibans et voir dans quelle
mesure il va les respecter ce qui pour
nous est important notamment continuer à
autoriser à les départs et ça ça va être
une autre opération vérité il n'est pas
sûr que leur filtrage autour de
l'aéroport soit particulièrement
bienveillants puisqu'on sait que depuis
qu'ils sont dans les villes ils ont
interrogé les gens ils ont interrogé les
toits les voisins ils ont filé liste de
collaborateurs alors il ya deux sortes
de collaborateurs tous sont
théoriquement gracié mais ceux qui
étaient dans des postes vraiment
critique très importants qui ont eu
affaire avec les talibans ou maille à
partir avec l'aliment probablement
seront inquiétés
et les familles de ceux qui sont partis
seront aussi probablement inquiété donc
il y a eu lieu en effet de craindre pour
cela et puis on n'a pas encore dit mais
dans le fond puisqu'il va y avoir un
sujet économique qui va prendre en
charge la reconstruction de
l'afghanistan
et s'il n'y a pas un gouvernement
inclusif comme on dit et bien ya un pays
qui est candidat il ya un pays qui est
candidat c'est la chine et la chine en
effet va leur dire 'attendez route de la
soie investissement les autoroutes que
les américains n'ont pas fait les
chemins de fer que les américains n'ont
pas construit nous nous pouvons vous les
faire et d'ailleurs on va vous endetter
un petit peu comme ça ça nous donnera un
pied de plus sur les terrains puisqu'il
ya évidemment beaucoup de matières
premières c'est un pays très riche en
matières premières qui ont été
totalement délaissé dans le passé régis
le sommier ce spectre chinois il devient
de plus en plus imminent d'une certaine
façon il est il et il n'est pas récent
les chinois le ministre affaires
étrangères chinois s'était affichée avec
une délégation talibane comme les russes
également il y avait eu une visite de
délégations à moscou en mars dernier
avec les chinois le ministre des
affaires étrangères s'est affiché bien
avant au mois de juillet bien avant le
comment la chute de kaboul donc cette
d'ailleurs les pakistanais n'ont joué
aussi pas mal pour rapprocher les
chinois avec les talibans et les chinois
ont d'une certaine façon appuyée les
talibans donc ça ça fait partie des pays
qui qui vise d'abord à une stabilité un
les chinois on sait qu'il ya la question
oui lourd qui est inquiet que le
critique pour eux il ne s'agirait pas
d'avoir un gouvernement talibans qui
alimentent en en gommant en sous sol une
révolte dans cette partie musulmane de
l'est de la chine de l'ouest de la chine
pardon et ça c'est un obsession des
chinois ensuite pour pour la question de
2,2 de la russie c'est clair que aussi
l'instabilité dans les anciennes
républiques soviétiques musulmane vous
qui ce temps le tadjikistan c'est quand
même très proche et il ya aussi pose
potentiellement des éléments
perturbateurs dont il ya d'ailleurs des
manoeuvres militaires qui ont eu lieu
entre ces pays et la russie pour
justement dire aux talibans attention
pas de pas d'agitation pas de voie là et
je pense que c'est pas du tout dans
l'intérêt des talibans de faire ça mais
justement avec ses deux partenaires en
particulier et avec l'iran qui comme
j'expliquais c'est s'est
considérablement rapproché des talibans
l'afghanistan notamment par le biais du
successeur de souleymane sy qui était le
gardien le chef des gardiens de la
révolution aujourd'hui et qui étaient
ceux qui étaient spécialisés dans
l'afghanistan à l'époque où sur les
manies et l e à la tête des gardiens de
la révolution là il ya eu véritablement
une inflexion et un rapprochement ya
tous ces pays qui sont là il ya aussi la
turquie faut pas l'oublier qui donc a
pas proposé donc ces services est en
train de négocier pour la gestion de
l'aéroport de kaboul la question n'est
pas tant que la turquie ait des intérêts
énormes mais elle peut à nouveau se
projeter à l'international et apparaître
comme ce qui est ne cesse de vouloir
apparaître c'est à dire comme une
puissance véritablement internationale
avec un comment une sphère d'influencé
et la voilà chacun essaie de combler ce
vide immense laissés par les etats-unis
en afghanistan en attendant le construit
des murs pour éviter les réfugiés mais
l'association merci en tout cas tous les
deux régis le sommier claude
blanchemaison est justement au coeur de
cette crise afghane dans l'accueil des
réfugiés en europe également pose
question les pays de l'ue eux qui nous
parviennent toujours pas à s'accorder
sur une politique commune d'accueil et
qui redoutent une nouvelle crise
migratoire sur le continent certains
pays renforcent leurs frontières et les
gens parfois des murs pour empêcher
l'arrivée des migrants les précisions
d'hélène masquelier
à l'extrême est de la turquie au milieu
des collines désertiques des blocs de
béton de 3 m 2 au sein de l'horizon
patrouilles renforcées poste de garde
tous les 10 kilomètres une muraille se
dresse sur la route de l'occident en ce
moment nos mesures pour prévenir le
franchissement de la frontière sont à
leur maximum
notre objectif est de rendre notre
frontière infranchissable et d'empêcher
les migrants de trouver un moyen de
traverser
le pays porte d'entrée principale vers
l'union européenne craint un scénario
semblable à celui de 2015 en marge de la
crise syrienne ankara avait alors
accueilli près de quatre millions de
réfugiés à quelques milliers de
kilomètres de là un autre point de
passage la grèce qui ne se montre pas
plus accueillante tandis que les forces
armées sont placés en alerte le long des
frontières athènes renforce son arsenal
législatif ce vendredi une loi a été
soumise au parlement grec afin
d'accélérer l'expulsion des migrants la
grèce n'acceptera pas comme lors de la
période 2015 2019 d'être la porte
d'entrée vers l'europe pour les flux de
l'immigration illégale la loi grecque
porterait également un coup aux
activités des ong travaillant à la
protection des migrants une mesure
dénoncée par le conseil de l'europe
le projet de loi sur les expulsions et
les retours suscite de sérieuses
inquiétudes
sur la route des balkans la prévention
est aussi de mise l'autriche et la
serbie lancé un message très clair
de cinterion contac in deux régions nous
sommes en contact avec les pays de la
région
béné dans ce moment si il y à une vague
de migrants ils sont en afghanistan
mais s'il ya une vague vers d'autres
pays
ils doivent être prises en charge par
les pays voisins et il ne faut pas
qu'ils se dirigent vers l'europe à
rhinebeck marc ayrault pas marre on est
collé une poche de ceux qui partent
d'afghanistan ont un objectif clair
l'europe de l'ouest et les états unis
ils ne sont pas nombreux à vouloir
rester dans les balkans occidentaux dont
nous nous montrerons solidaire avec tous
mais nous ne faisons pas office de
parking pour les migrants
selon le haut commissariat aux réfugiés
près de 500 mille afghans devraient
quitter le pays d'ici à la fin de
l'année face à la crise afghane
la commission européenne pousse les
états à appliquer une politique de
quotas une démarche jugée prématurée par
l'allemagne et la france qui souhaite
harmoniser les critères d'accueil comme
en 2015 les états membres peinent à se
mettre d'accord et la politique
européenne d'accueil des réfugiés se
retrouve de nouveau mise à l'épreuve
et la crise en afghanistan on agite pas
qu'outre atlantique et dans les pays du
golfe c'est toute l'asie centrale qui
craint que l'instabilité déborde sur
leur territoire le kirghizstan le disais
tout à l'heure un caïd mende et des
sessions de formation militaire sous
l'égide de l'ôter c'est la fameuse
organisation du traité de sécurité
collective dans la russie fait partie
notre envoyé spécial à bichkek antoine
claireaux pour plus de précisions
pendant trois jours des troupes en
provenance de russie du kazakhstan au
corps du tadjikistan se réunissent ici
dans l'est du kirghizstan afin
d'interagir avec l'armée locale pour des
manoeuvres conjointes et ces mouvements
de troupes sont bien entendu lié à
l'actualité en afghanistan et à ce
propos sergey lavrov a évoqué le cas de
la formation du nouveau gouvernement
afghan
oblige tous les talibans ont indiqué
publiquement qu'une telle invitation
serait fait peut-être qu'elle a déjà été
reçue pendant que nous parlons nous
voulons soutenir le processus de
formation d'un gouvernement qui réflète
très l'ensemble de la société afghane
y compris les talibans bien sûr et
d'autres groupes ethniques non seulement
l'état chun mais aussi les ouzbeks les
hazaras aider tadjik
seul un gouvernement aussi inclusif
commune et usages de dire sera en mesure
d'assurer une transition durable vers
une nouvelle vie pour nos voisins
afghans
si c'est de cela qu'il s'agit je pense
que nous participerons volontiers une
telle cérémonie avec d'autres pays
invités qui ont une influence sur la
situation dans ce pays
en attendant moscou ne reste pas inactif
et multiplie donc les manoeuvres
militaires avec ses alliés de
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective dans un premier temps avec
l'ouzbékistan et le tadjikistan c'était
à la fin du mois d'août ou encore en mer
caspienne l'objectif de ces exercices
est double à la fois rassurer les pays
alliés d'asie centrale de la russie mais
aussi dissuader les potentielles
velléités des islamistes qui se trouve
en afghanistan
lecture élite et internationales c'est
aussi le coup d'état en guinée le chef
des putschistes en guinée a promis
aujourd'hui la mise en place d'un
gouvernement d'union nationale chargé de
conduire une période de transition
politique
il assuré qu'il n'y aurait pas de chasse
aux sorcières contre l'ancien pouvoir en
attendant ministre sortant et président
des institutions ont été convoqués pour
une grande réunion à conakry retour en
sueur se couche avec yamina benguigui
des tirs nourris et à l'armé lourde ont
résonné ce dimanche matin aux abords de
sékoutoureya ne palais présidentiel où
se trouvait alpha condé le président de
la guinée conakry
quelques heures plus tard on apprenait
que le chef d'état avait été arrêté par
le groupement des forces spéciales du
pays malgré le démenti du ministère de
la défense affirmant que l' attaque
avait été repoussée sur ces images on
voit un président avachi ému et
une tentative de coup d'état opéré par
le colonel mamadou doumbouya le présumé
nouvel homme fort de la guinée donne
rapidement des justifications la
situation sociopolitique l'économie pays
nous dysfonctionnement des institutions
républicaines
l'instrumentalisation de la justice nous
qu'utile m'en vais revoir et citoyens du
respect des principes démocratiques
la politisation à outrance de
l'administration comme étant la table si
financier la pauvreté et la corruption
endémique et mener la vie républicaine
des guinéens à travers vos communautés
nationales du rassemblement et du
développement c'est la beauté à prendre
ses responsabilités vis-à-vis du peuple
souverain de guinée et dans sa totalité
depuis des scènes de liesse ont eu lieu
notamment dans la capitale en allant se
manifeste de la joie parce que on était
là on a beaucoup souffrir avec le temps
bon dieu nous a montré quelques uns qui
est plus puissant que lui avant tout
c'est l'impatience
de son côté le chef de l'onu a condamné
par la suite un coup de force et demandé
la libération du président guinéen je
suis personnellement de très près la
situation en guinée je condamne
fermement toute prise de pouvoir par la
force des armes et je demande la
libération immédiate du président alpha
condé l'ancien légionnaire de l'armée
française mamady doumbouya n'en est pas
à sa première opposition
récemment il avait manifesté sa volonté
d'autonomiser le groupement des forces
spéciales par rapport au ministère de la
défense ce qui avait suscité la méfiance
de conakry
l'homme qui mène ce putsch est un ancien
légionnaire français le colonel mamadou
doumbouya à la tête du groupement des
forces spéciales de guinée conakry
depuis 2018 il était sous la menace
d'une interpellation imminente en raison
de doutes sérieux sur ses projets
alpha condé accède au pouvoir le 7
novembre 2010 le 2 mars 2020 alors que
son deuxième mandat arrive à terme il
invoque une nouvelle constitution lui
permettant d'entamer un troisième mandat
le 18 octobre 2020 après un référendum
boycotté par l'opposition
désormais le groupement des forces
spéciales appelle le reste de l'armée à
se joindre à lui mais un proche du chef
d'état a affirmé à l'hebdomadaire jeune
afrique que les forces fidèles à alpha
condé n'avait pas dit leur dernier mot
et pour en parler nous sommes avec l
louis keumayou président du club de
formation africaine bonsoir lui que
d'être avec nous mamani du brouillard
l'instigateur du coup d'état donc
déclaré aujourd'hui la mise en place
d'un gouvernement d'union nationale
chargé de conduire une période je suis
de transition politique il promet qu'il
n'y aura pas de chasse aux sorcières
mais clairement est ce qu'on peut
craindre aujourd'hui en guinée conakry
une dictature
non faut pas galvauder le terme aux
dictatures je pense qu'il y a il ya un
manque de respect de la constitution qui
a d'abord été opéré par le président
alpha condé qui a ensuite été accentuée
par ce coup d'état mais de là à parler
d'une dictature je pense qu'on est dans
une période très incertaine où l'on ne
sait pas très précisément où sont les
leviers de pouvoir on sait qui tient le
pouvoir non c'est pas où sont les
leviers et quelle sera la résistance
certains disent que le l'ancien
légionnaire français a attaqué au nom de
certaines amitiés française pour
défendre des intérêts d'autres parlent
de tas d'autres théories certains disent
qu par panafricanisme
on devrait soutenir ce coup d'état parce
que c'est un coup d'état qui devrait
perdurer condamné pardon ce coup d'état
parce que c'est un coup d'état qui vient
fragiliser davantage un président qui
était patriotes qui voulaient prix de
nationaliser un certain nombre de mines
dans son pays mais je crois pouvoir
beaucoup trop vite en besogne
le vrai problème ici c'est que comme
dans la plupart des pays africains d'une
part on a un vrai problème de pauvreté
un problème de développement économique
qui est évident il ya un problème de
répartition des richesses et puis il ya
surtout que la démocratie est une grève
qui tarde à prendre la preuve en est que
malgré le fait que le président alpha
condé qui a été élu en 2010 pour donner
pour représenter l'année zéro qui
représentait l'année zéro de la
démocratie or en guinée malgré cela il
est devenu la caricature de lui même en
étant obligé de quitter le pouvoir sous
le coup des militaires après que les
civils n'ai pas réussi à le faire au nom
à lui faire renoncer un troisième mandat
on vous l'avait dit en scène est un
ancien légionnaire français hammam a dit
dong où il ya à la tête des forces
spéciales guinéenne vous l'avez évoqué
mais pour ceux qui ignoreraient cette
histoire quels sont les liens avec la
france quel rôle avait-il auprès du
président alpha condé justement
ce lieutenant colonel qui a été dans la
légion étrangère française s'est proposé
à proposer ses services à son be parce
qu'il estimait qu'après toutes les
années de formation qu'il a passées au
gabon au sénégal en france en israël et
dans d'autres pays et les charges
opération qu'il a connue il pouvait être
utile à son pays au niveau de la
répression de du terreau d'exo par
exemple et donc le président alpha condé
a spécialement créé cette unité d'élite
spécial pour lui et l'a placé à la tête
de cette unité en lui faisant une
confiance totale j'ai entendu dans le
reportage que il y avait des soupçons
qui était porté sur sa personne mais le
fait est que le président alpha condé a
continué de lui faire confiance dont il
n'a pas fait il n'a pas prêté
l'attention toute l'attention nécessaire
aux mises en garde qui lui était faite
par rapport à cette année à cet ancien
légionnaire de la légion étrangère
française donc il ya eu un rapport de
confiance entre eux officieusement
certains disent que l'unité a été mise
sur pied pour réprimer les manifestants
et surtout éviter que les manifestations
politiques prennent de l'ampleur mais
officiellement l'unitaire été mise sur
pied pour lutter contre le terrorisme
qui reporte de la guinée à partir du
sahel lors de sa première prise de
parole à il a également annoncé vouloir
rassembler le pays et mettre fin au mal
guinéen le pays c'est vrai traverse une
crise politique depuis l'élection
présidentielle du mois d'octobre selon
vous est ce qu'il peut avant les les
moyens de cette ambition
ça va être difficile de le faire même si
c'est au bout de 18 mois parce que je
suppose qu'il demandera un agenda de 18
mois pour arriver à passer le pouvoir
aux civils je pense que ça va être très
long parce que le mal guinéen ne se
limite pas au viol de la constitution ou
à la gabegie financière d'ailleurs que
sur le plan économique on peut remarquer
que malgré tout ce qui a été dit sur le
bilan d'alpha condé sur le plan
économique il a quand même réussi à
relancer la machine économique de la
guinée donc je ne pense pas qu en 18
mois il puisse résoudre cette crise ce
mâle guinée comme ils l'ont qualifiée
parce que le mal est profond il est
d'abord celui d'une nation d'un pays qui
n'arrivent pas fait relations on a
beaucoup d'ethnies en guinée et ses
ethnies là aujourd'hui quand on parle de
la vie politique en guinée on a la liste
sous le prisme ethnique de savoir ce que
sont les malinkés ce que sont les
soussous ce que sont les gens de la côte
et ainsi de suite donc la guinée
forestière donc si on n'arrive déjà pas
à créer cette nation guinéenne le reste
sera très compliqué pourtant c'est un
chantier qui doit être menée aujourd'hui
dont il ya cette dimension ethnique qui
doit être réglée et à la dimension
économique et surtout la dimension de la
crise sanitaire qui vient accentuer
cette crise économique et la répartition
des maigres richesses dont dispose de
pays ça aussi il fallait s'en occuper et
je ne pense pas qu'en 18 mois encore une
fois même en faisant un gouvernement
d'inclusion les militaires et ceux qui
travailleront avec eux ils arrivent
merci beaucoup louis keumayou d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
pour nous apporter votre analyse et
cette arrestation qui sont donc sonné le
glas d'une carrière politique plein de
rebond mais qui est alpha condé éléments
de réponse avec grace d'aia et bilal la
boisson
c'est un homme qui revient de loin né en
1938 fils d'un cuisinier originaire du
burkina faso issue de l'ethnie malinké
alpha condé fait ses études en france
dès l'âge de 15 ans il y étudie
l'économie le droit et la sociologie
docteur d'état en droit public il
enseigne à l'université de la sorbonne
et c'est depuis la france qu'il entre en
politique dès les années 60 en 1977 il
crée le mouvement national démocratique
parti d'opposition qui deviendra ensuite
le rassemblement du peuple de guinée
condamné à mort par contumace en 1970
par ahmed sékou touré premier président
du pays après l'indépendance alpha condé
rentrer en guinée en 1991 et se mesure
contre lens 1 à compter lors des
présidentielles de 1993 puis
1998 s'il en sort perdant l'opposant de
longue date commence à inquiéter le
pouvoir en place alpha condé se présente
comme modernisateur opposé notamment à
l'excision et aux mariages forcés son
discours séduit la jeunesse et les
femmes
arrêté et condamné à cinq ans de prison
puis libéré au bout de vingt mois sous
la pression internationale
l'homme voit enfin son avènement arrivé
en 2010
le professeur alpha condé est élu au
deuxième tour malgré une forte
contestation des résultats réélu en 2015
il réussi à modifier la constitution
2020 suite à un référendum boycotté
alors par l'opposition dès lors il ne
lui est plus impossible de briguer plus
de deux mandats consécutifs
cette parade lui permet d'être à nouveau
élu malgré une forte contestation
populaire et des manifestations
violemment réprimées
- alpha cuende
simulik élus conforme à la tradition
gj demain le peuple de guinée et ce mot
l'honneur de respecter et de faire
respecter scrupuleusement
les dispositions de la constitution
delwar
et des hommes de j 6 à 83 ans alpha
condé a à son actif des chantiers dont
il vante le bilan la réalisation de
barrages hydroélectriques la révision
des contrats miniers ou encore le retour
de l'armée dans les casernes mais
l'économie guinéenne est fortement
éprouvée par la fièvre ebola puis par le
cos vide 19 malgré son sous sol riche
notamment de bauxite mais aussi de fer
d'or ou de diamant la guinée vont encore
plus de la moitié de sa population
vivre sous le seuil de pauvreté
en france à présent à huit mois - même
de huit mois de la présidentielle
emmanuel macron et marine le pen les
deux finalistes de 2017 conserveraient
leur avance au premier tour c'est en
tout cas ce qu'indique un sondage ifop
fiducial pour lci et le figaro est
toujours au premier tour garder avec
l'hypothèse que xavier bertrand soit
candidat de la droite et avec un eric
zemmour candidat lui également emmanuel
macron arriverait premier avec 24%
marine le pen seconde avec 22 % suivi de
xavier bertrand 15 % jean-luc mélenchon
9% le vainqueur de la primaire écolo 7
5% dont on connaît pas encore le nom et
eric zemmour enfin 7% à égalité avec
anne hidalgo à noter que xavier bertrand
serait le seul à l'emporter au second
tour face à emmanuel macron avec 53 %
contre 47 pour l'actuel locataire de
l'elysée
et pour décrypter et analyser ce sondage
plein d'enseignements nous sommes avec
nicolas vidal éditorial bonsoir nicolas
vidal merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france on nous a appris apa faire
confiance aux sondages mais tout de même
ils se suivent parfois se ressemblent ce
nouveau sondage pour la présidentielle
donne une nouvelle fois emmanuel macron
quasiment à égalité avec marine le pen
dans le duo tête inexorablement comment
peut-on l'analyse et belmont soir
stéphanie oui vous avez entièrement
raison c'est finalement ce sondage c'est
toujours le même vous l'avez dit se
ressemblent ils se suivent et se
ressemblent bien en fait si
l'affrontement rêver un pour le système
en place avec la certitude de voir
emmanuel macron rester au pouvoir un
abri de 8,22 mais finalement au moins la
question qui me pose ce soir
rappelez-vous législatives s'étaient
pratiquement 60% restants sur les
municipales avant pareil finalement moi
je vois ça comme un théâtre d ombres qui
permet de ne plus réfléchir à la
démocratie dans ce pays et forcément est
forcément vous le savez ça alimentant la
palabre politique et y moi c'est quelque
chose qui cache un peu la réalité de ce
pays cette fracture démocratique de fond
donc des sondages c'est bien mais vous
savez depuis dix ans depuis 20 ans
aujourd'hui les français sont devenus
des sondages descendez des pourcentages
et pour certains des segments mais
toujours pas de réflexion toujours pas
de big bang sur l'abstention 60% des
français n'ont pas voté aux législatives
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est son
agent que peu d'intérêt parce que si on
commencerait d'un détail des forces
politiques en présence on boit thème qui
a une certaine je vais le dire je veux
dire un gros mot une certaine
homogénéité
selon moi c'était une grue nicolas vidal
il ya aussi les sondages et les
personnalités testées celles qui ne sont
pas loin de moi l'idée de dire qui est
une manipulation mais il peut y avoir
effectivement une forme de suggestions
dans les sondages et peut-être peu de
créativité finalement bien entendu bien
entendu une suggestion de marine le pen
emmanuel macron vous imaginez bien qu
emmanuel macron il a envie d'avoir
marine le pen aujourd'hui fin
aujourd'hui en avril 2022 dans quelques
mois face à lui ce sera beaucoup plus
simple et il met par contre moi je suis
pas convaincu que ça sera le résultat
final je ne suis pas convaincue
qu'anders 2022 nous aurons peut-être
emmanuel macron et marine le pen face à
face ce duo qui arrange bien tout le
monde quand je parle de tout le monde
soyons clairs je pars de la classe
politique dans son ensemble donc oui on
nous fait le jeu du duo mâcon le pen
marine le pen et c'est quand même
considérablement mais considérablement
pasteurisé depuis quelques mois elle a
épousé il faut le dire elle a épousé les
idées du système et d'ailleurs ça fait
penser à quelque chose ça me pensez vous
savez à matteo salvini en italie qui lui
aussi finalement a épousé l'idée du
système dangereusement et puis rendre
une nouvelle fois marine le pen et je
crois que ça va être le l'enjeu de cette
présidentielle c'est finalement on ne
veut plus de sortie de l'union
européenne elle veut plus sortie de
l'euro est elle finalement l'épousé
aussi la c2a chain la communauté voilà
c'est de la chance ça c'est extrêmement
important parce que marine le pen est en
train de reculer partout parce que moi
je pense marine le pen elle est
terrorisée par les sondages et elle elle
aussi elle est le nez dans les sondages
très très régulièrement et je pense que
tout ça manque de conviction et ça me
fait penser un peu voyez-vous a
finalement à des convictions format de
tuyaux d'arrosage ils savent je crois
que dans la situation noté aujourd'hui
ça va être très très compliqué et ça va
être extrêmement intéressant de voir qui
va être face à face en avril 2022
stéphanie cdh a comme
cour européenne des droits de l'homme et
du côté un nicolas vidal de l'opposition
les républicains et les socialistes
malgré la multiplication des
candidatures sont eux plutôt en tout cas
alors on parle en mauvaise posture
ben oui parce que ça renvoie une
fracture crucial qu'ils ont pu depuis au
moins 20 ans c'est entre les
progressistes emmanuel macron année le
choix entre le parangon et les
souverainistes et finalement les ré bic
est qu'est ce qui se passe chez
républicain déjà il ya tellement de
candidats qui sont presque plus nombreux
que les cadres chez l air donc ça ça va
être une question je suis assez amusé un
même dévasté parfois devant le nombre de
candidatures qui a mais la réalité c'est
que les républicains ils sont bacrot
compatibles je l'avais déjà dit d'un
édito finalement ce sont des
mondialistes qui ne s'assume pas ils
sont européistes à mort il part de
souveraineté nationale et européenne
pardon là d'ssus comme dell et bertand
donc en fait ils ne peuvent pas se
distancer des manuels macro il savait la
politique c'est souvent des couloirs
présidentielle le problème section ce
même couloir et emmanuel macron est très
très loin devant et il suit dans fait
que je sois very pécresse xavier
bertrand michel barnier qui est ancien
commissaire européen vous voyez
finalement cap à l'espace de papier à
cigarette entre tous ils ont pas ils ont
rien à faire valoir les républicains
aujourd'hui et ça c'est un vrai problème
et d'ailleurs je crois qu'ils se sont
pas ils sont abstenus de commenter la
proportion aux élections initiative ne
serait ce que pour xavier bertrand il
faut rappeler xavier bertrand ses 17%
des inscrits 10 7% les esprits donc
c'est quand même un sivu minable est-ce
que la possible candidature d'eric
zemmour pourrait-il rebattre les cartes
ben oui parce qu'eric zemmour il fait la
conjonction en fait vous savez entre la
souveraineté et l identité vous saviez
7e ce qu'avait fait nicolas sarkozy
quand il était conseillé par patrick
buisson son conseiller il n'avait pas
adopté la ligne buisson et c'est
peut-être aussi pour ça qui a perdu
dernière fois mais finalement eric
zemmour il fait cette option chaud entre
souveraineté identité ça qu'on partage
ou pas être des déshérités mais il faut
quand même lui reconnaître qu'il éclaire
sur tous les sujets régaliens et saïda
il incarne aussi un espoir pour beaucoup
de français il rebat les cartes et
rappelez-vous dès le début du mouvement
du gilet jaune on parlait souvent mais
moi peut-être d'un candidat qui
sortirait du lot qui sortirait du sérail
et peut-être et peut-être qu'eric
zemmour et va être ce candidat là on
voit qu'il est déjà en précampagne on le
voit il a fait la promo de son bouquin
dans quelques jours le 17 septembre je
crois donc finalement il va faire une
campagne sous couvert de promotion
littéraire mais eric zemmour il est
vraiment dans cette idée là et il je
crois qu'il pourrait vraiment vraiment
bousculés l'échéance de la
présidentielle après on verra c'est
encore long il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
choses qui vont se passer beaucoup de
mouvements sociaux vous le savez par
emmanuel macron mais vraiment eric
zemmour je pense que c'est très
intéressant et dernière idée ce qui
était vrai pour et marine le pen avant
2017 ils sont désastreux des balles
entre deux tours eric zemmour
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il peut jouer
comme une soupape de sécurité pour d'une
france plus conservatrices plus
traditionnelles qui pourrait attendre
sagement que eric zemmour se présente
donc effectivement je pense qu'il a pris
la place de marine le pen dans cette
soupape de sécurité populaire et
démocratiquement un peu mon analyse sur
eric zemmour aujourd'hui merci en tout
cas à vos nicolas vidal je rappelle que
vous êtes éditorialistes merci à vous
les paradis fiscaux toujours aussi prisé
par les banques aux européennes c'est le
résultat d'une étude qui vient d'être
publiée par un bureau de recherche
indépendant els révèle que les
principaux établissements bancaires du
vieux continent au registre chaque année
14 % de leurs bénéfices totaux dans des
pays avec un bas taux d'imposition
d'avis khalifa
le temps passe et les choses ne changent
pas le monde de la finance et
impitoyable l'appât du gain toujours
plus grand malgré la révélation de
plusieurs scandales l'expliquent en 2014
puis les pats damas peppers deux ans
plus tard
l'évasion fiscale se poursuivent pour la
majorité des banques européennes
chaque année ce sont quelques 20
milliards de soit 14 % de leurs
bénéfices totaux qui sont enregistrés
dans 17 territoires à la fiscalité
particulièrement favorable plus
communément appelée paradis fiscaux
malgré l'importance croissante de ces
questions dans le débat public et dans
le monde politique les banques
européennes n'ont pas réduit de manière
significative le recours aux paradis
fiscaux l'observatoire a réalisé cette
étude entre 2014 et 2020 les 17 pays
considérés comme des paradis fiscaux
doivent combiner deux éléments un taux
d'imposition effectif inférieur ou égal
à 15 % mais aussi une productivité des
banques par employé particulièrement
élevé en tête de ces territoires le
royaume uni et ses îles vierges mais pas
de tout soupçon les bénéfices
comptabilisés par les banques dans les
paradis fiscaux sont anormalement élevé
280 3000 euros par salarié contre
environ 65000 euros dans les pays qui ne
sont pas des paradis fiscaux
de quoi suggérer que les bénéfices
comptabilisés dans les paradis fiscaux
viennent principalement d'autres pays là
où les services sont produits la
conséquence directe est évidemment pour
les états sur les 36 établissements
passés au peigne fin
l'observatoire estime qu'un taux minimum
de 15 % permettrait de générer 3 à 5
milliards d'euros de recettes
supplémentaires pour les pays européens
avec un taux de 25% ces chiffres
triplerait pour atteindre 10 à 13
milliards d'euros des chiffres qui
forcément remettre la question de la
justice fiscale sur la table en ligne de
mire les multinationales des discussions
sont en cours au sein de l'organisation
de coopération et de développement
économiques pour une imposition minimum
de 15% justement des profits est de ces
mastodontes pour lutter contre les
paradis fiscaux et pour nombre
d'économistes ce n'est clairement pas
suffisant les dirigeants qui font de la
fraude fiscale délibéré doivent aller en
prison mais si les banques et les
avocats qui les aides doivent aussi
faire la prison je pense que ça sera que
par ça j'en ai discuté par un ami avocat
avec un ami avocat fiscaliste dire que
cette méthode qui permettra de faire
respecter les règles mais il faut voir
aussi une autre chose c'est cette
concurrence fiscale partout sur la
planète est liée à la mondialisation et
on n'y arrivera pas dans la
mondialisation il faut démondialiser il
faut revenir avec des règles nationales
à des états qui ont les règles qui
peuvent fixer les règles de justice et
les règles fiscales qu'ils veulent et
les faire appliquer c'est comme ça par
cette démondialisation qu'on reviendra à
plus de justice fiscale pour moi mettre
tout le monde en prison c'est plutôt
utopiste surtout lorsqu'on regarde de
plus près qui se trouverait en ligne de
mire quelles banques usent le plus de
ces procédés eh bien on trouve en tête
de liste la britannique hsbc plus de 62%
de ses bénéfices avant impôts ont été
comptabilisés dans des paradis fiscaux
entre 2018 et 2020 elle est talonnée par
l'italienne monte des patxi donc quasi
50% des bénéfices ont la même destinée
en france c'est la société générale qui
est en pôle position avec 13,8 pour cent
de ses profits placés dans les paradis
fiscaux devant le crédit agricole et bnp
paribas l'évasion fiscale un embarras
pour les états qui ne date pas d'hier en
2017 le lg oxfam dénonce et déjà ces
pratiques quatre ans plus tard le bilan
est sans équivoque aucune amélioration
notable au delà des beaux discours il va
falloir davantage de volonté aux états
pour enfin sortir de l'enfer des paradis
fiscaux mais en faire justement est-il
pas pavé de bonnes intentions il reste
avec nous dans quelques instants après
une courte pause dans notre rubrique
qu'en pensent les français ce soir notre
reporter est allé à la rencontre des
antilles pas sanitaires ils sont souvent
assimilés à des heures anti vaste mais
le sont-ils vraiment pourquoi la
mobilisation perdure tel nous tenterons
de répondre à ces questions rester avec
nous
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
si paris cette saison avec lionel messi
remporte la ligue des champions ou du
symbolisme en termes de technique ce
sera absolument parfait et ils veulent
une fanfare d'un possible pour la coupe
du monde 2022 qui est la priorité de
l'émirat pourquoi le qatar utilise le
sport le foot plus particulièrement
comme outil de soft power ici vous
regarde en termes d'argent le faut ce
qu'on dit c'est de l'argent tu sais
c'est que dalle en fait ces pilotes donc
si vous voulez aujourd'hui être affiché
à travers tous les continents avoir une
image et en plus un an de la coupe du
monde c'est rêver pour le qatar parce
qu'on va reparler d'eux et encore pour
des raisons de manière plutôt
méliorative plutôt faible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'il ya une période de stabilité
en haïti est ce que ça a été est ce que
ça existe et je la fais plus de cent ans
que l'on avait assisté à l'assassinât
d'un président de la république en haïti
l'état de droit a été véritablement mise
à mal pour permettre l'assassinât sur un
mode de crapuleux on a vu en fait se
constituer des armées privées qui
aujourd'hui ont totalement perdu le
contrôle de leur trou et lorsque ces
gangsters sont recrutés par des hommes
politiques ça vous donne une situation
pratiquement de guerre civile nous
sommes ici au coeur d'un système
extrêmement un briquet d'intérêt à la
fois intérieure et extérieure de toute
façon
mafieux cela ne peut que contribuer à la
dé construction d'un état moderne et
démocratique
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups positif n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent
en soir vient des lignes aujourd'hui on
est une gauche l'extrême
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande île d review
[Musique]
mecili dette on parle de 150 mille
enfants donc amérindiens métis et inuits
qui ont été envoyés dans ces pensionnats
comment ça s'est passé le début de cette
politique
coloniale était de venir en territoire
et prend dix enfants sans le
consentement des parents et ils
arachides leur territoire pour les amis
dans d'autres régions dans 12 provinces
très très loin l'objectif est de tuer
l'envié dans la fin juin justement 182
tombes anonymes ont été découvertes sur
le site d'un ancien pensionnat à
cranbrook en colombie britannique
c'est la troisième découverte de ce type
en un mois on parle ici de génocide de
politique génocidaire ça va au delà de
la culture mais plutôt un crime contre
l'humanité auprès d'une nation
[Musique]
il est 21h merci nous rejoindre en
direct sur arte france pour cette
deuxième partie d'émission
place à notre nouvelle rubrique dans
quelques instants qu'en pensent les
français nous irons ce soir à la
rencontre de ces anti pas sanitaire
c'est france est déterminée à ne pas
lâcher face à un dispositif qu'ils
jugent liberticide déjà près de deux
mois mobilisation et un dossier épineux
pour l'exécutif accusé de couper le pays
en deux alors quelles stratégies pour
les partis politiques dans la course
pour 2022 le passé ni terre où la
vaccination obligatoire on en débattra
avec nos invités
[Musique]
et avant notre focus impasse sanitaire
cette déclaration très commentée de
françois molins ce le procureur général
près de la cour de cassation la cour de
justice de la république croulerait sous
les plaintes déposées par les français
contre le gouvernement des plans qui
concernerait la gestion de la crise du
coc vite par l'exécutif on en parle tout
de suite avec notre reporter guillemin
rossi bonsoir guillemin vous êtes devant
ces chorales justice de la république
est ce qu on sait combien de plaintes
ont été déposées
oui tout à fait et stéphanie alors 14500
1 c'est le nombre de plainte qui aurait
été déposée depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire auprès de la cour de
justice de la république c'est en tout
cas le nombre qui a été donné par la
cour de cassation à nos confrères du
parisien cette cour de cassation qui
précise que la très grande note très
grande majorité de ces plaintes sont en
fait des plaintes des plaintes type
c'est à dire des formulaires pré remplie
que les gens ont téléchargé signé et
renvoyer un phénomène sur lequel
françois molins est revenu hier soir sur
lci écoutez
c'est un phénomène qui est nouveau
certainement dû au développement des
modes de communication et d'internet qui
affecte la cour de justice de la
république
effectivement il y a des milliers de
plaintes qui arrive le même phénomène de
plaintes massive existe au niveau du
pôle santé publique du tribunal
judiciaire de paris c'est un phénomène
qui concerne la problématique dans son
ensemble le volet droit commun ou le
volet ministériel
alors cette cour de justice de la
république elle a déjà jugées recevables
certaines de ces plaintes contre des
membres du gouvernement reçus depuis le
début de cette crise sanitaire je pense
par exemple à ses neuf plaintes émanant
d'un collectif de médecins c'est dans le
carde le cadre de ce dossier que la cour
de justice de la république avait
ordonné rappelez vous le 15 octobre
dernier des perquisitions au domicile et
au bureau de plusieurs membres ou
ex-membres du gouvernement par exemple
olivier ferrand ou encore l'ex premier
ministre edouard philippe où l'ex porte
parole du gouvernement si bête ndiaye a
noté que le parquet de paris quant à lui
a également ouvert quatre information
judiciaire contre x en novembre et là
encore en lien avec la gestion de cette
crise du cofidab merci guillemin rossi
pour toutes ces précisions
huitième journée de mobilisation donc
samedi m manifestants contre le passage
ni terre ils seraient de moins en moins
nombreux à battre le pavé selon les
chiffres fournis par le gouvernement
chaque week-end faux répondent en choeur
ces anti passe alors qui sont ces
français qui ont manifesté tout l'été on
les présente souvent comme des anti vat
mais le sont-ils vraiment est-ce qu'ils
vont maintenir la pression sur emmanuel
macron à la rentrée nous sommes allés
les rencontrer sur le terrain et vous
allez voir que leur détermination est
sans faille reportage lucas léger avec
moi pour parler de ce mouvement inda
bigot organisatrice de manifestations
mougeot indh a tout simplement est ce
que vous pourriez m'expliquer déjà vous
qui avait été gilet jaune pourquoi vous
avez décidé de retourner dans la rue à
l'occasion de cette loi sur le pacs
sanitaires
de toute façon depuis le début du
mouvement des gilet jaune effectivement
il a beaucoup évolué dans le sens où au
delà de 2 d'exiger une baisse des taxes
à meilleur vivre une meilleure justice
fiscale et sociale on s'est rendu compte
que au delà de tout ça c'est une
mauvaise gouvernance que nous avons et
donc à chaque fois qu effectivement on
ce qu'on constate qu il y adeux des lois
liberticides des décrets liberticides
un changement fondamental de notre
société ainsi que dans nos vies on sait
on on s'est dit on peut pas on peut pas
on peut pas laisser faire et encore
moins faire comme si ce n'était pas un
problème général cela fait partie aussi
des deux 2 va dire de cette force des
gilet jaune d'être partout et contrer
ces décisions qu'est ce qui est à la
base de votre engagement parce que vous
pourriez vous dire voilà je me concentre
sur ma famille et je laisse la société
suivre son cours ben oui c'est vrai
quelqu'un qui ne se sentiraient pas
concerné par ce qui se passe dans notre
société pourrait penser ainsi mais la
société c'est ce qu'on va léguer aussi à
nos enfants demain en tant que maman
c'est quelque chose qui ne qui qui ne
rentrent pas dans ma tête en fait la
lutte contre le pass sanitaire est ce
que c'est une colère légitime des
français à votre avis complètement
complètement c'est une colère légitime
de de toute personne qui se sent
concerné par ces libertés on ne peut pas
nous pousser vers une vaccination
obligatoire alors que nous nous la
réfutons on n'a pas à nous dire tiens tu
ira pas au cinéma non tu peux pas on
était enfant ouzou donc tu n'as pas fait
un test pcr ou qu on n'est pas des codes
barres sur pattes il est instauré juste
comme une épée damoclès sur nos têtes
pour nous forcer à nous vacciner tout
simplement en se jouant de nos libertés
en prenant en otage nos libertés jusqu'à
ce qu'ils obtiennent ce qu'ils
souhaitent c'est à dire leur quota des
50 millions de vaccinés des deux doses
une fois que ce sera fait vous allez
voir que le pas s'il va disparaître
alors on est devant le fouquet's et un
lieu hautement symbolique le 16 mars
2010neuf ya une manifestation qui a très
mal terminé ici le fouquet's a été
endommagée est ce qu'on peut faire un
lien entre les mâles et gilet jaune et
les manifestants contre le passage ni
terre et je sais que ça plaît pas à tout
le monde de comparer ces deux mouvements
mais qu'est ce que vous vous en pensez
il n'y a pas de comparaison à avoir les
gilet jaune encore une fois à part à
part cette couleur jaune et cette
étiquette ça reste comme je le dis et je
le répète des hommes et des femmes de
notre société des membres de ce peuple
qui souffre des actifs de notre société
qui revendique on qui tire ont la larme
qui alertons quant à cette gouvernance
qui est en train de tout casser donc il
n'y a pas deux il faut pas faut pas
tomber dans ce genre de clichés sinon ça
va créer des amalgames et on a trop été
habitué depuis 40 ans à tous ces
amalgames là on voit quand même qui a
beaucoup moins de violence dans le
mouvement contre le pass sanitaires
comment vous pouvez expliquer ça tout
simplement parce que c'est une auteure
d'une autre partie de la population c
est peut-être qu'il soutenait les gilet
jaune mais kindle qui avait peur de
sortir c'est monsieur et madame tout le
monde c'est c'est vraiment les actifs de
la société c'est vraiment les parents
les grands parents les enfants
les enseignants aujourd'hui cette
population elle est sans étiquette en
fait c'est vraiment le peuple le peuple
dans toute sa diversité qui est dans la
rue alors je pense que macron prend des
pincettes et a dû vraiment tirer les
rênes de ses forces de l'ordre
est-ce que la vaccination ça va être le
thème politique de la rentrée à votre
avis mais complètement ils nous ont déjà
préparé toute cette propagande
médiatique depuis 18 mois et ça ne va
pas arrêter de toute façon c'est une
certitude puisque à la rentrée on nous
parle déjà d'une troisième dose après ça
va être quatrième dose cinquième de
aussi et ben ça va être comme ça
continuellement quand est-ce que ça va
s'arrêter cette mascarade c'est la
question que moi j'aimerais poser au
peuple quand est ce qu'on va se
réveiller et reprendre nos vies en main
je veux dire ce ne sont pas ces élites
de dire ou comment faire ou quoi faire
ou qu'est ce qui est bon ou pas pour
nous sans nous concerter à un moment
donné à cette concertation qui manquent
et non pas depuis macron mais c'est
depuis au moins quinze ou vingt ans mais
macro lui ça a été flagrant elle est là
la réalité
et des manifestants qui sont donc plus
que jamais mobilisés on l'aura compris
beaucoup d'inquiétude vous venez de
l'entendre se passe va-t-il durer dans
le temps le ministre de la santé évoqués
il ya deux jours une extension du pas
salutaire au delà du 15 novembre dans
les zones les plus affectées par le
virus emmanuel macron avait dit en
juillet nous devrons nous poser la
question de la vaccination obligatoire
d'où cette question de notre face à face
ce soir parce sanitaires ou vaccination
obligatoire quelle stratégie pour les
partir de 2022
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir en
direct joëlle mélin députée européenne
au rassemblement national bonsoir madame
mais d'un merci beaucoup d'être avec
soin en direct dans ce face à face sur
son plateau stéphane pelé vice-président
du mouvement la france vraiment bonsoir
à vous également
première question ces fameux ps que
emmanuel macron eu raison de mettre la
pression avec le pass and i ter
finalement est ce que c'est un outil que
vous jugez efficace dans la lutte contre
le colis de même si évidemment vous
n'êtes pas un scientifique un n'a
échappé à personne alors si je suis un
scientifique docteur mais pas en
médecine non mais c'est pour la
plaisanterie que je dis ça par ailleurs
ce que je crois c'est que il ne faut pas
tirer de conséquences et de conclusions
définitives sur toutes ces questions il
faut être très tranquille il faut
regarder l'état du pays et surtout le
comparer sur le plan international ce
soir la nouvelle zélande s'apprête à
rouvrir progressivement ses frontières
parce que elle a bien géré sa crise
sanitaire et au même moment le japon par
exemple ou les jeux paralympiques et
olympiques se sont déroulés
contrairement à ce qu'on pense le japon
et ce soir un pays complètement claque
curé parce qu'il n'a eu aucune stratégie
efficace c'est exactement le cas de
l'australie qui elle par contre a tenté
une autre stratégie et qui est obligé
aussi de se re confiné donc ça signifie
qu'en fait
chaque état je crois a tenté une parade
et moi je suis pas là ce soir même si
c'est un face à face mais en tous les
cas je ne suis pas là pour défendre
spécifiquement le président de la
république il y aura un moment c'est
l'élection présidentielle où il sera
question de son bilan ce que je peux
dire c'est que
grosso modo la plupart des français lui
font confiance dans cette stratégie
contrairement à ce qu'on pense et on va
en parler bien sûr il ya des gens dans
la rue bien sûr il ya une contestation
mais quand on voit que
64% des français seront bientôt vacciner
complètement totalement même si ensuite
un rappel n'est pas une troisième dose
d'ailleurs et c'est pas à la médecin qui
est là ce soir que je vais la prendre
des vaccins on en fait toute notre vie
il ya des rappels il y compris des
rappels à 45 ans pour certains vaccins
quand on sait que les 18 29 ans ont pris
conscience complètement de l'intérêt de
ce pass est la vaccination et que ce
soir ils sont
74% et vacciné je me dis que oui le
président de la république a bien fait
d'être dans une stratégie extrêmement
énergique et donc ce soir je pense que
les gens vaccinés et les gens conscients
réalistes pragmatiques sont très très
majoritaires dans ce pays un jour elle
m'est la même analyse que stéphane klein
on rappelle que vous êtes médecins en
formation même si vous n'exercez plus
déjà aussi même question pour vous
est-ce que cet outil a été
efficace contre la pandémie est ce que
il y avait le choix finalement pour ou
contre
le choix on nous l'a retirée on nous l'a
retiré parce que malgré des sommes très
importantes de recherches qui ont été
mises sur la table dès le mois de
janvier 2020 on ne nous a proposé aucune
alternative et les quelques essais qui
ont été faits au moins un titre
compassionnel c'est à dire quand on n'a
rien d'autre ont été rejetées d'un
revers de main voire même condamné je
pense à l'ivermectine je pense à la
chloroquine on ne s'est pas donné les
moyens de prouver que ça ne marchait pas
vous vous rendez compte à quel point on
en est deux contres preuves et en
matière de responsabilité là
contre-preuve n'existe pas en
conséquence on n'a pas eu d'autre
d'autre choix que cette vaccination
elle a marché dans bien que mal pourquoi
parce que nous vaccinons actuellement à
propos d'une souche de l'initiale
j'entends la première épidémie la
première vague qui a déjà disparu depuis
plus d'un an donc elle marche de moins
en moins bien sûr des mutants elle en
est vite entre nous soit d'irlandais
vite quand même les formes graves et
elle a permis de passer un certain cap
mais tout ceci est terriblement un
parfait tout autant que le pass
sanitaire qui scientifiquement ne tient
pas vraiment la route il ya trop de
trous dans la raquette sonne tout ça et
vite
80% des contaminations vous allez me
dire c'est beaucoup mieux que rien de la
même façon qu'on a vu renaître des
règles sanitaires extraordinaire qu'on
avait complètement perdu et c'est ainsi
que l'on a vu de grippe ou presque plus
de gastro ou presque je suis allé
regarder dans la littérature il ya même
une diminution des morts subites du
nourrisson pratiquement plus de
varicelle à part quelques épidémie qui
sont surgit par de si de là presque plus
de ces maladies pour lesquelles je
rappelle quand même que l'on a proposé
et que l'on a imposé aux vaccins
obligatoires en début 2018 ça n'a pas
fait tiquer les parents cette
association de 11 axa n'a pas été évalué
et donc là il ya un vrai oui voilà bien
vrai
votre invité marseillaise que je salue
étant moi même originaire de cette très
belle ville
si je comprends bien le choix
essentiellement aurait dû être peut-être
celui de la vaccination obligatoire et
peut-être d'ailleurs irons-nous compte
sur ces maladies la planification mais
au sujet de tous les cas c'est ce qu'il
ya derrière notre débat juste avant il
dhabi go on l'a vu un an dans ce
témoignage de luc hallé géo nous dit la
vaccination c'est l'enjeu de de la
rentrée clairement vous êtes d'accord
avec ceux des no 6 a va être cet enjeu
clairement de la vaccination obligatoire
là pour le moment parle du pass
sanitaire mais on a toujours dit que
c'était une forme de vaccination
obligatoire qui ne disait pas son nom
c'est d'ailleurs le reproche qui lui est
fait non je pense pas que ce soit ce
débat là qui va structurer les
prochaines élections et la prochaine
élection présidentielle par contre oui
très probablement il y aura un débat
entre
des gens plutôt appuyé sur la raison et
puis ceux qui sont plutôt appuyé sur
l'expression disons de sentiment et je
mets pas là une ligne de partage
péjorative un entendez bien mais je ne
considère pas que ceux qui sont dans le
rationnel en forcément raison et ce
qu'ils ont le sentiment rector vous le
savez il ya un os grande ceis sociologue
qui vient de sortir un livre assez
intéressant qui s'appelle donc qui parle
des sentiments de la vie et qui montre
comment progressivement les luttes celle
que vous montrez dans la rue par exemple
sont passés de luttes sociales
salariales pour la défense entre classes
à des luttes de plus en plus simplement
pour la reconnaissance le respect et ça
oui je pense que ça sera une ligne de
fracture très forte et c'est pour ça que
je vous le dis moi je ne défends pas à
plus le président de la république que
les autres le débat va se structurer
mais il est clair qu'il y aura un débat
entre une forme d'action publique
respectueuse et une forme l'action
publique peut être un petit peu trop
cassante un petit peu trop arrogant
arrogant pas assez respectueuse et il
est clair qu'avec le mouvement que je
représente ici ce soir le mystère des
citoyens la france vraiment nous
défendons une approche respectueuse nous
pensons que plutôt que nous nous appuyer
sur des peurs et de faire descendre les
gens dans la rue il faut s'appuyer sur
la concertation les citoyens pour faire
émerger des solutions et peut-être qu'on
va y venir mais nous avons par exemple
une grande concertation en cours sur le
système de santé avant de vous redonner
la parole joëlle mélin je voudrais vous
faire justement écouter emmanuel macron
un café de la vaccination impôts dit un
thème politique de rentrée souvenez vous
de son allocution le 12 juillet dernier
en fonction de l'évolution de la
situation nous devrons sans doute nous
poser la question de la vaccination
obligatoire pour tous les français
faites vous vacciner c'est la seule
façon de vous protéger et de protéger
les autres c'est une question de
responsabilité individuelle
de sens de l'esprit collectif
7e au 6e dont dépend notre liberté à
toutes et tous joëlle mélin clairement
là on est au coeur du débat et on est
dans ce débat qui fait bondir tous et
dont il passe sanitaire cette somme de
privation de liberté je m'adresse à la
médecin vous êtes mais également à celle
qui appartient au rassemblement national
donc faut-il rendre la vaccination
obligatoire
écoutez c'est un faux débat c'est un
faux débat parce que l'on est sur des
principes quasi philosophique ou de
liberté ce que j'entends parfaitement et
qui se conçoit sauf que on a
complètement oublié que le vrai problème
c'est un virus complètement inhabituelle
dont on ne connaît pas l'origine qui a
des particularités qu'on a jamais vu
même la grippe espagnole n'a fait que
deux hivers et un été on n'a jamais vu
de virus qui nous fasse maintenant 8
c'est pratiquement deux hivers deux
étaient pratiquement 4 mais il faut
savoir quand même que cette épidémie
était probablement en route en juillet
2019 en chine
donc nous sommes avec un virus tout à
fait extraordinaire nous ne pouvons pas
nous positionner actuellement pour la
simple et bonne raison c'est qu'avec un
peu de chance on va échapper à la suite
la suite et c'est ce qui se profile à je
vous rappelle quand même qu'il ya un
virus colombien est un virus sud
africains qui sont très compliquées
issue là aussi de mutation complexe il
faudra bien voir comment on aborde tous
à l'urgence des urgences et pas se poser
le problème de savoir si oui ou non la
vaccination doit être obligatoire c'est
qui va se charger de préparer par avance
des vaccins en catastrophe sur ces deux
virus si tenté qu'il fasse le tour de
monde en s2 l'est en ouest comme on l'a
eue maintenant depuis deux ans donc
après il ya deux attitudes soit celle
qu'on a toujours eu à l'égard de
certains vaccins qui était de les
recommander de les conseiller fortement
et la solution de l'obligatoire n'est
que dans certains cas très précis et en
particulier les virus qui ne lutte pas
je rappelle quand même que différer à je
pense surtout à la po lyon qui est une
maladie très grave dont le virus mais
n'est pas un mouton mais qu'il faut
absolument garder parce que les dégâts
sont considérables et qu'actuellement ce
n'est pas un virus anodin loin de là il
faudrait pas qu'ils apparaissent donc on
est obligé de garder cette vaccination
obligatoire mais le problème de dire à
la rentrée on a vacciné obligatoirement
pas c'est un faux débat on sait pas ce
qui va se passer à la rentrée on ne sait
pas ce qui se passera au mois de janvier
surtout si l'on voit apparaître des
épidémies comme on l'a vu très
régulièrement je vous rappelle l'automne
précédent le varia anglais on le laisse
entrer parce que les frontières ça
n'existe plus puis le variant delta on
le laisse entrer parce que les
frontières n'existent plus honnêtement
tout ça aurait dû être arrêté beaucoup
plus tôt il y à des fautes de gestion
extrêmement lourde je vous parlais tout
à l'heure un autre faute de gestion plus
pour mon ami et je suis physiquement
beaucoup plus lourde en clair un point
de vue légèrement différent avec tout le
tout le respect que je vous dois en tous
les cas pour votre parcours sur le plan
universitaire
vous parlez d'un sujet mais j'allais
dire c'est un débat que vous pourriez
avoir si tel était le cas éventuellement
avec le ministre de la santé donc
stratégique entre stratégie on peut
quand même dire que globalement la
stratégie en france a été relativement
réussies on n'y peut rien c'est comme ça
qu'on soit pour ou contre le président
de la république je pense que on peut
être aller très longtemps à certain
nombre de considérations
ce dont certaines émanent justement ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que pourquoi
d'ailleurs le président parce que c'est
une émission où on analyse aussi un peu
les choses sur leur ressenti politique
pourquoi le président insiste tant sur
la vaccination c'est parce que je pense
qu'il allie mais il a l'idée de tenir sa
victoire au bout d'un certain niveau de
vaccination qui est en effet
probablement effacera une gestion qui a
été beaucoup plus difficile concernant
les masques et d'autres d'autres
péripéties mais qu'est ce qu'il faut
retenir de cette crise nous pas une
attaque comme le fait madame qui quoi
qu'on en dise fait partie de cette
formation politique est un peu celle qui
joue les apprentis sorciers pour la
plupart des mouvements sociaux qui se
retrouve avec et gilet jaune qui se
retrouve avec ces gens dont on voit des
des pancartes totalement lamentable qui
se met en place ce mouvement sans forme
finalement ce mouvement un petit peu
comme ça avec des tas de revendications
qui ne ce qui ne se complètent pas à la
fin qu'est ce que ça donne dans les
urnes d'abord souvent rien du tout la
vue aux régionales on a vu le plafond de
verre auquel s'est confronté le
rassemblement national c'est à dire que
la plupart de ses candidats n'ont pas
réussi à s'imposer dans les régions
parce que les gens ont été extrêmement
comment dire claire réalistes ils se
sont dit non on préfère avant des gens
relativement sérieux plutôt que des gens
petit peu agitée sur ces questions là et
puis surtout ce qui va être intéressant
par contre c'est de savoir comment dans
la prochaine campagne on va prendre en
compte l'avis des citoyens et c'est là
que je dis que nous avons une grande
différence sur ce plateau c'est que je
crois qu'il ya en effet un besoin de
concertation il ya énormément citoyens
qui ne sont pas satisfaits même si je
corrige une information sur votre
plateau vous disiez que 30 % seulement
des gens s'apprêtait à voter c'est faux
le dernier sondage pour la
présidentielle on a 70 % d'intentions
d'aller voter
oui c'est ça mais oui mais bon peu
importe cette invitée mais néanmoins il
vaut mieux corriger puisqu'il est
éditorialiste de votre chaîne dont
70 des français se déclarent prêts à
aller voter ils sont encore motivés
c'est pour ça que ce soir mois plus tôt
ou de manière différente de madame je
lance un appel notamment à tous les
citoyens mobilisés dans les collectifs
dans les associations citoyennes dans de
nombreuses villes a plutôt soutenir
éventuellement une candidature qui
seraient issus de ce mouvement citoyen
car qu'est-ce qui a marqué tous ces
mouvements c'est qu'ils n'ont débouché
sur rien du tout on va laisser quand
même la parole à l'ats joël ménard qui
il va peut-être vous répondre
oui oh je vais vous répondre à de la
même façon que je le fais depuis bientôt
30 ans à ce genre de considérations
voilà dont acte je voudrais quand même
faire remarquer une chose fondamentale
vous qui dites que la gestion de la
crise n'a pas été si mauvaise que ça que
tout compte fait passer il n'y a plus
rien à voir on en est bientôt à la fin
ou autrement j'étais même vous dire
qu'une chose
simplement si je suis bien informé
votre ministre le ministre de
l'intérieur de l'époque allait l'autre
de l'époque au mois de mars 2020 quand
le ms a proclamé la pandémie a refusé
aurait refusé d'activer la cellule de
crise ordinaire du ministère de
l'intérieur qui permet à tous les
services de sécurité civile de se mettre
en route et d'être ensuite alimentés par
les mères via les préfets de département
je ne remets pas en question votre le
sérieux de votre part vivement votre
bien vous avez raison
voilà à partir de là la gestion de la
crise et et pizarro bourg est confiée
aux ars dont on a tous vu qu'elles ont
évidemment accompagné des secours qui
étaient en retard en permanence
d'information en particulier ceux de
santé publique france
environ fera le point dès l'instant
qu'on sentira sort un peu de cette crise
on fera le point sinon il faut garder
toute son énergie pour
bakou contre l'épidémie au delà de ça je
suis tout à fait étonné autant de
français vivent avec des peurs
irrationnelles
il est urgent que les politiques les
rassure qu'on cesse d'avoir des peurs
sorti de nulle part sans aucun fondement
scientifique moi j'entendais même pas
des raisonnements les gens me disent une
partir et moi je sais que chez vous
vous êtes bien isolé dans votre
formation politique à vouloir faire en
sorte que les français n'aient plus peur
alors que c'est le carburant principal
de votre candidate oui oui bon a coûté
cher monsieur je vous laisse ce genre de
phrase parce que voilà encore une fois
trente ans que je la fiom largement
laisse penser selon les élections il ya
des moments dans tout parti politique
quel est le parti politique qui existe
comme cela depuis 40 ans et plus même
s'il a un petit peu changé de tant de
noms entre temps il n'y en a pas il n'ya
que le nôtre est le nôtre tient le coup
largement il y à eau et des bas dans une
période si l'angle a forcément des hauts
et des bas et particulièrement nous
avons nous une idée extrêmement clair
d'une doctrine su fonder en fonder sur
ce que nous croyons de ce que nous
devons apporter aux citoyens dans leur
liberté leur place et le respect qu'on
leur doit mais au delà de ça nous avons
aussi une idée de la place de l'état de
l'état qui doit offrir un cadre
sécuritaire le cadre de toutes les
sécurités la sécurité physique la
sécurité de tous les jours et dans la
rue mais aussi la sécurité sanitaire et
c'est que sécurité sanitaire elle a été
bafouée très gravement très gravement
par le gouvernement macro mettant à mal
toute l'économie voilà j'étais très
sincèrement l'économie s'il ya bien un
domaine sur lequel ce pays a réussi
c'est bien celui là on a passé ce sera
le prix d'un modèle à approcher cette
année merci également à vous joël ménard
était avec nous en direct et c'est la
fin de cette émission merci beaucoup de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve demain à 20
heures pour un prochain numéro est
second en fin de soirée à tous et
prochain point évidemment sur
l'actualité à 22 heures
d
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mecili dette on parle de 150 mille
enfants donc amérindiens métis et inuits
qui ont été envoyés dans ces pensionnats
bhl comment ça s'est passé le début de
cette politique
coloniale était de devenir un territoire
et 39 ans sans le consentement des
parents et les arachides leur territoire
pour les amis dans d'autres régions
dindo province très très loin l'objectif
était de tuer il a aidé d'un an fin juin
je suis mon 182 tombes anonymes ont été
découvertes sur le site d'un ancien
pensionnat à cranbrook en colombie
britannique
et c'est la troisième découverte de ce
type en un mois on parle ici de génocide
de politique génocidaire ça va au delà
de la culture mais plutôt un crime
contre
l'humanité et celle d'une nation